all right shawna
hello shawna where'd you grow up where
are you from i am from detroit michigan
um i grew up on the east side of detroit
really more so towards like
middle school late elementary i moved to
a mile and mountain in the warren area
that's really where i made like most of
my friends and whatnot but um
been in michigan
ever my whole life honestly and tell me
about your family you had mom and dad
yeah i um live with both um i had both
in my life the whole time um yeah both
parents in my life
um it was it was good at first like i
had a really good sense of family you
know being biracial you know i feel like
i got a really good um
sense of diversity in my life i feel
like that played a big part in my um
like played a big role in my life
um it was good you know we grew up
pretty decently wealthy like my grandma
went to work my mom went to work like
my dad you know y'all
were living comfortably
it really wasn't until i'd say like
middle school it was
it kind of just went downhill
um unfortunately
drugs got a hold of um my family like
you know pills um
opiates more so and uh
yeah we've kind of shifted apart and
haven't really been the same since uh
you know my parents are still together
but
it's definitely not the same
we're small i feel a little it feels a
little broken sometimes for sure but um
but no like serious abuse in your
childhood no not serious like abuse i
never got like you know beat on or
nothing like that you know i got
disciplined when my parents felt
accordingly but it wasn't nothing crazy
or nothing how school
um one more time how far did you go in
school um i graduated school i
finished i didn't go to college but uh
that just wasn't really
working for me yeah what kind of work
have you done
um for so when i was in
like you know
not elementary high school
i was doing like fast food retail
as i got older and as my social anxiety
kind of
gotten a little worse by time i stopped
wanting to do sales
and um one day i found myself in 2019
being a dancer
and that was kind of my job for like
good two years until um covert hit at a
strip club yeah yeah strip club after
our suites um
we didn't really dabble into the
extras but you know don't shame on it
either i have you know i know people who
do that and
they get their money they live their
best life but i was more so into the
dancing like i just danced it was it was
cool you know i was with friends
i had some it was actually pretty decent
i definitely don't knock the dancing
game i actually enjoyed it it was pretty
cool it just had some of its uh
you know it's cons it's not the best
environment to always be around it can
mess with your self-esteem
they don't tell you that some nights you
don't make any money at all if you know
it's one of those nights so
that also used to bum me out mess with
my self-esteem and
yeah it had those moments but all in all
it
got the job done paid the bills that
drugs are a part of your life yeah um
again
somewhat are i've definitely slowed down
a lot but back yeah really when i was
dancing when i got more into it you know
you're around all of that stuff how old
do you know i'm 22. so i started when i
was 19. yeah 2019 i started
um yeah i
i was around all of that you know i
wasn't crazy with it you know i wouldn't
say i was
addicted to it or nothing like that you
know i see my family go through
addictions and i know that's not what i
wanted to be
so i definitely um would have my limits
with it but i
you know i did a lot i was you know
doing coke a lot i was doing a lot of um
e
like i try molly sometimes uh
definitely slow down a lot like i don't
really
it's just not something i want to
cope with all the time i want to learn
how to cope with my mental health in
different ways
but um
yeah that was definitely a big part of
my life i slowed down a lot and uh it's
more so like a party once a while social
thing for me
um shrooms is kind of more so my like my
thing my medicine i know some people
like to call it which i would too
personally you find them helpful very
much so i think i like i'm very
spiritual
so i feel like it
answers questions that i feel like i
really need answered sometimes i feel
like i see things um what they're for
at times
mushrooms to help you see things from a
totally different perspective yeah
absolutely yes something sticks with you
after you're off them yeah honestly yes
personally it does some people
may feel different but
honestly most who've done it would
probably say the same thing yeah i've
seen things from a different perspective
like i had a trip where
i really realized i had childhood trauma
and i don't know why it was that trip i
was listening to a kendrick lamar song
and i just i don't know i realized i
needed like to work on my childhood
traumas and it still has stuck with me
and it kind of
i don't know it was like a relief to
know that
that was one of the things kind of also
hindering me the things i went through
as a child and a teenager you know
so i definitely think that helps a lot
and you discovered it at a certain age
that you you're struggling with a
borderline personality disorder yeah i
noticed honestly i my attention my
intentions my um emotions were intense
when i was
like younger but you know i just thought
i was a real over-emotional child you
know just sensitive kind of just brushed
it off
it really wasn't until like high school
i've noticed it was
extreme like it was pretty bad
and you know unfortunately growing up
like in like with my parents i didn't
really
get the
help that i needed it kind of got
brushed off the shoulder
mentally they weren't the best to me all
the time unfortunately still love them
still care about them still see them but
uh they weren't the best emotionally and
mentally so that also kind of made
things worse and not better
and i finally decided to get
like a professional opinion and when i
was 18 i went to my psychiatrist and
yeah she pretty much summed it up for me
which i kind of had a feeling that's why
i wanted to say something
but yeah found out 2018 um i'm intrigued
taking trintellix but
that's not really the best i don't know
medicine has not been my thing it's like
something telling me to
not take it like
i don't know if it's my depression if
it's
some i i don't know like my subconscious
i i don't know but it's really hard for
me to take medicine like so hard
and a lot of people tell me you know
well it'll help you got to keep taking
it
but i don't want to i don't know why
you backed off from taking the
medication
yeah i feel like i should be able to
do
like
figure out on my own like it kind of
makes me feel not normal like i know
that's weird to say like it's medicine
like a lot of people take it but it just
doesn't make me feel
normal and i already don't feel normal
so i feel like medication kind of
makes it real like is real for me but it
really just kind of makes it more real
for me if that makes sense
so like
anxiety depression anger do you go
through any of that all three
like i don't even know which it's
different days are worse
um
yeah it just depends on would you
describe you
um i think he would describe me as
i don't know i definitely have talked to
him about
these things before i told him i feel
like my mental health has been
a problem i feel like it slows him down
or it holds him back um
he seems to disagree
he seems to you know feel like he's
something he can be around he seems to
think that
i'm not that person i have imaged in my
head i think i'm crazy sometimes it
makes the relationship exciting
i'm sure right
yeah is it your instability that is the
biggest issue
yeah i think it's really my instability
um like my slip like i don't like how i
can slip so switch so
quickly and so aggressively and so
intensely
and i really feel like it's a problem
like i'll
i don't know i'll just
be sitting there chilling and having a
decent time
smoking my weed trying to relax and like
i'll
hear something on the tv that like
triggers me like a trigger word like i
don't like i don't know something that
triggers me and i get like really in a
weird mood like i just get like an
attitude i get groggy like if i feel
like i didn't do enough that day or
didn't go up and do like orders delivery
orders or try to make any money i feel
lazy i feel ashamed i
i get upset you know i start screaming
trying to toss stuff around the house
because my house isn't clean and it's
like a domino effect and then it's just
at its peak and i
it's so hard to calm down and i
i don't know it's just hard to calm down
i feel like sometimes
you know he doesn't even know what to do
and it makes me feel really bad like
when it's all said and done when i kind
of snap back into it i feel
horrible
like i feel really horrible like
it's terrible i hate feeling like that i
feel like i just lost it and
it's not a good feeling
and has there been good points in your
life but it hasn't been a problem or has
it been steadily definitely um i find it
more so like when i'm
you know doing something like going on a
trip i haven't really traveled much but
when i do little trips like to chicago
or to ohio i find myself more at peace
like being away
you know from the state i feel like
being here kind of plays a big part too
yeah traveling really i feel like
eases it um
just going outside just like having a
good time being like young enjoying my
youth like doing things that i feel like
you should do in life kind of make me
feel better
and some days like if you're stimulated
you kind of
yeah
fails whatever void you're frustrated
and angry absolutely when i feel like
when i'm doing something like and at
home you maybe get bored yeah i think
that's really it too i think i'm at home
i get bored i don't know what to do like
i'm having a really bad uh
time in my life trying to find out what
i want to do for my career and um
you know i don't know what to do i don't
know what to get into i don't know where
to start
and being at home kind of
solidifies that because i feel like i
kind of just sit at home all day and
sleep and smoke and watch tv and cry
and it's like no one wants to do that
it's annoying it's frustrating and i
find myself yeah when i go out
it's better but lately i've been finding
myself getting bored even going out like
i'll be out and
you know detroit is so small like
there's only so much to do and
so much drama here someone's always
shooting or ruining something or
someone's fighting so it's hard to even
enjoy myself like now hanging out with
my friends or you know my boyfriend or
whatever
and it's
like even that's like a problem for me
and i found myself wanting to go home
early not enjoying myself
and um
yeah sometimes it feels like it's
getting
worse like i feel like you know some
days
i'm feeling better i can do more things
like it's not affecting me i had a good
day
and then other days i feel like a rock
like i can't do
anything
and
yeah it's it's pretty i don't know it's
lonely it's hard to feel like um
it's hard to get anybody to try to
understand and it's hard to relate you
know people will say yeah you know i
have depression anxiety i feel it
but i genuinely just
don't think like a lot of my close
friends have that the intenseness of
it like i do you know what's the most
extreme it's gotten for you
um i'd say honestly when i get
really
i think the one of the most extreme
times is when i got into it with my
boyfriend at one time and
um it was just it was you know it was
going through a lot we hit a rough patch
we just moved into our apartment you
know it was just kind of
just trying to settle into the apartment
you know it was a lot of i had a lot of
friends over just doing stupid stuff and
um you know he found himself getting a
little frustrated and we just you know
argued a lot and one night
i it was just a really bad argument and
i
remember just blacking out
i remember like
half naked trying to pull him back into
the house and
just screaming at the top of my lungs
trying to get him to stay and
just looking
looking insane throwing stuff breaking
doors
outside trying to pull him back in the
house because he wanted to get some air
wasn't even going nowhere you know
someone called the cops
um they lied they said he tried to pull
me up the driveway but i can assure you
that did not happen that was me trying
to pull him back in the house
and um
yeah it was just really it's really ugly
um i've also had some moments with my
parents like i ran away one time like
4am i was tired
i just was really
frustrated and angry
packed my stuff and i just walked all
the way to my grandma's house and she
stayed
a little distance it showed up at what
age
um
it got worse i'd say once we honestly
moved
from warren to 23 miles so that would be
sixth grade
um that's when i've noticed like my
anxiety kind of peaking like i was in a
new school it was hard for me to make
friends
um that i was in a different environment
you know i was around a more mixed crowd
of people in school like a more diverse
crowd like my neighborhood was really
mixed and um
i was used to that and then
growing up in a predominantly like white
neighborhood where they have nice houses
and they think they're better than you
and you live in a rinky-dink apartment
out there
like yeah it was it was hard um you know
we got like
called the eight mile crew and stuff
like
it was you know it wasn't the best and
you know i feel like my parents didn't
quite understand
how hard that transition
from those two different environments
were for me and i think that also kind
of
helps like stem
the um just the anxiety from going to
school like i was just didn't talk as
much i was noticed i was more scared to
be myself
i noticed like i would
lie about stupid stuff to try to like
fit in and make friends
um
yeah i just noticed my behavior was
different like i really wasn't the same
and when i tried to express this to my
parents it kind of
you know my mom had her own issues going
on so i don't think she was emotionally
available to be there for me
and my dad worked a lot so i don't think
he was either quite so he definitely
tried but you know him and my mom argued
a lot so i just don't think they were
emotionally available to be there for me
and you know it's
you know i grew up you know and
i'm learning to deal with that and
handle my own things and again i still
love them i still see them you know i
took my break from them we had some
issues when i first graduated but um
it's okay now
so that definitely really uh
started to show then and i seemed like
it's gotten worse i just feel like i've
some days are a little more easier to
cope with than others
now
rather than it like actually healing i
find it hard to actually heal i find
myself coping more are there other
people in your family yeah i have um two
brothers other people that have the same
issue oh they have the same issue um my
grandma
has um
you know i i don't think she has
borderline but she does have really bad
depression and anxiety
um like even now unfortunately it breaks
my heart but um you know she's going
through it now like her my grandpa got
her divorce and
she's her her dog she feels very alone
you know she's done a lot for us like
the family in general
and i feel like you know she doesn't get
enough recognition and i
this makes me sad for her but yeah she's
always had that she grew up in a really
rough household
um she
she she had a pretty
bad um
and
yeah definitely seeing her
going through those kind of made me
realize
i
where i kind of get it from i do think i
definitely get it from her you know my
mom would always tell me
not to be like her and always make
little side comments but i definitely
see um
that in her my mom kind of has it
sometimes like
she'll have her moments where she feels
you know depressed but i definitely
don't think it's on me and my
grandmother's level like
she honestly gets depressed
when
she's like
in pain or something like like i don't
know you know she takes pain pills for
her pain and
you know whatever and i think that's
really when she gets the most
depressed and upset grant she's had her
moments like she just broke her wrist
and that bothered her you know
stuff like that but no definitely i
don't think she understands absolutely
not do you feel like you're
just different than everyone else
yeah i've always felt like that i've
always felt like it was hard for me to
get along with my family i feel like it
was hard for me to keep friendships and
like relationships
like i feel like i push people away
a lot i know i do i don't mean to and i
try to explain my best to people is it
like you're self-sabotaging or
self-destruct i i do feel like it's
self-sabotage it feels like it's
something like
bad like i want to say i have like
voices but this feels like an evil
little voice just always telling me to
like
stay away from people you know people
don't
it's like always it's like your own
you're your own bully like it's always
something telling you
not to be happy like i'll try to
get motivated and get excited about
something and
it's like something in my brain will
make me not be happy about that no more
um
like my brain really like downplays my
happiness it's like it's hard
you know to for me to even find
happiness it during like the day over
little stuff
you know like it seems like the only
time i'm really
happy is when i'm rolling a blunt
because i'm not
stressing no more like it's
no one's to feel like that's [ __ ]
what do you worry about what are you
afraid of in your life um i'm afraid
that
i'm not going to be able
to
be who i want to be i'm afraid i won't
be successful i'm afraid i won't find
myself
and i'm afraid that thought alone will
hurt my like i will hurt myself one day
like i you know tell my boyfriend often
like one day i think i'm really gonna do
like hurt myself like it's
it's building up you know like i've only
had one
attempt in suicide when i was younger
and my parents didn't take too kindly
for that so i didn't really have another
one
just more so thoughts
but um
it's getting more there it's more
intense it's more in the back of my mind
it's pretty heavy some days and
you know i go on social media and i see
people you know that i know or just
people in general doing things that i
want to do doing things that i love you
know modeling acting like doing all
these things i wish i could pursue
and it's like a smack in the face like i
helps i feel like i help so many people
like i really do have a good heart i
feel like i'm a pretty good friend and i
it's like a slap in the face you know
especially you gotta understand that the
social media is
this distorted view of everyone's life
yeah it is and that's why i try to tell
myself i really do i really do try to
tell myself that
but you know somebody posts they're
they're real yeah you know they're real
they're you're seeing the worst of the
work the best of the best
exactly
and yeah that's what you know
i tell myself that's what a lot of
people tell me too
and i don't know i know that's true
but i guess it's like what if i could
really
live
that i don't know what if i could really
live that life like
why i don't want to be so
normal like living such a mediocre life
like i see my family do that like i want
to do something better like i want to
get us out of poverty like i want to
take care of the people i love and you
know people have done a lot for me
regardless of the [ __ ] i've gone through
and i feel bad that i probably won't be
able to take care of my grandma
grandmother before she passes away or i
can't take care of the people i care
about
because like i can't get it together and
i feel like my
mental health really is
blocking that like i cannot get it
together
and it's hard like it's hard you know i
had to delete all my social media like
even now i'm not on it because of that
reason like i
can't seem to make it make sense to me
like it's just social media like i can't
get that through my head so i had to
take a break from that
um
yeah i just really needed a pause on
that for a minute because it's you know
modeling and all of that because it's
really been an issue i think it's really
me needing to like get myself together
and find out
what i want to do and i'm scared i won't
be able to do that in the mind state
that i'm at right now you feel like it's
just a
just something you were born with and
you just you have to fight against it
yeah
yeah definitely i do feel like it was
something i was born with and it's just
something i'm gonna have to live with
and
deal with and that thought also scares
me like i cry because i don't want to
pee like
i want to live like that every day like
i don't want to
feel like i
rather be dead like every day every
other day like it's horrible like no one
wants to feel that way especially when
it's like not even
anybody specifically making you feel
that way it's you
like how do you win that battle
you know
realistically i know i probably should
take my medication and i probably should
take help serious more serious but
i don't know it's it's hard it's it's
hard it's like what can a therapist do
what do they understand i feel like like
what can medicine do for me for real is
it almost like the
the borderline mindset that you have
keeps you from taking the medication
yeah i definitely don't have the third
line yeah yeah
i definitely it's like
the problem itself is causing the
problem yeah pretty much yeah
my mind won't yeah bro it won't let me
do it it's like
you don't need that you know like
no
like this is how you're supposed to be
like you're supposed to feel this [ __ ]
up like you don't need
that to feel better like no you you need
to feel
bad like this
it's like my
mind feeds like off that negativity
sometimes and it's
like disgusting almost like
it's like who am i like what is like
seriously like i literally just want to
have a
decent day in my own mind is
i can't even take medication because my
mind is trying to tell me this is how
i'm supposed to be
you know like it's
like nothing
in my life there's no voice in my head
telling me that it's okay to take this
and it's okay to be happy it feels like
there's i'm not allowed to be happy
and
i don't know why i've always kind of
felt like that since do you have some
good days
i have i have some good days yeah
um you know
i try to find
the good days and little stuff now like
if i
have enough money to
get something like one of my favorite
foods i find that a good day if i got to
see the water you know i find that a
good day now if i
didn't like have some stupid
interruption and i really think it's
just
again my intense emotions making days
bad too but you know
yeah every time i feel like there's like
just nothing
in the way nothing bothering me like
nothing
stopping me from having a good day no
triggers
then yeah but you know all of those
things like you know it can be hard to
like
stay happy like i get frustrated during
the day really quickly like if
like on the way here it was really bad
traffic and it was really irritating me
like i was starting to get anxious like
this traffic is too much like it's
like i can never have a decent day i can
never have a good day like it's always
something
like if a tire went flat and we were on
the way somewhere that probably ruined
my entire day like we we could have a
great day now we have a flat now i'm
irritated and now i just want to go home
like it's kind of like that you know and
it's hard for me to have good days but
i've really been working on it because i
need those good days i really do
tired of having bad days
like i'm i'm tired of
feeling like this
but
it's
you know it's not something you can just
shut off as easy as i will
as much as i wish i could just turn it
off and just
be
you know normal it's not does not work
like that
at all
so um
again yeah really more so learning how
to cope so i can learn how to heal
better for sure
so yeah all right shauna thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
yeah i wish you the best of luck thank
you i appreciate it you deserve you
deserve to be happy
yeah thank you i feel like
almost anyone everyone deserves to be
happy and
anyone going through mental health i i
feel it
like
sucks
but yeah i agree we all deserve to be
happy i think in the short life that
we're living all right thank you
you